Saying I'm biased is fine. I don't really care if you don't want
to listen to me. That's fine. But just give me the take that
was wrong. >> I I forgot that Brezie was on Sorry.
I I literally as you said that I ended the streamful things to
each other. What are you doing? >> Shut up. >> Can
you guys
need a segment for tomorrow? JTO, shut the up. >> Can't
pull the trigger. Her fingers are too weak from gooning to watch
a
>> Why is it always me, man? This resi sp the whole time.
always.
>> No, I think just making making fun of a guy grandparent
who he's like caring for is probably a little bit over the line.
I don't know. Maybe I'm a little bit on that fact. But I feel
that's a little bit kind of over the line. >> Such a loser.
You are such a double standards loser, man.
>> Let me see if I Oh, there we go. Cool, cool, cool, cool,
cool. >> Okay. So, you think you have to recuse yourself
from coverage?
I think he should have recused himself from being the like core
point of that coverage and being the person who when when
>> why is the core point Becket? >> Because he made
himself the core point because when Willie was having in a conversation
with him. >> No, that is you when you say that you are
citing one thing Jason said one time where he said I am someone
you could have reached out. >> Was there anybody else?
Okay. Was there anybody else who Cherry was going through for
these allegations other than just dog? >> Yes, me.
and Twitter. Yeah, she just posted it on Twitter. Yeah, >> she
posted on Twitter. But okay, but was there like when it came
to like who was >> actually hold on, I'd have to check
this. But wasn't >> the meaning? >> Yeah, the meaning
of everything with Cherry was what she posted on Twitter. I think
that's the only coverage. It's the only coverage I did as far
as I've seen from Queen and J. I think that's the >> But
just uh Okay, just welcome in
awkward. Hello. We're just trying to get through the the bias
exists conversation right now. Okay. >> Okay. Well, yes,
obviously the bias
>> That's fine.
>> But coming out and then having a situation where somebody
who you're advocating for as a victim comes out with a huge info
dump about apparent relationship is obviously going to be like
I don't know damaging to the claims in some way that Destiny
is a unique. >> It looks It looks really bad. It look It
looks bad. That's it. It looks bad in like the same way that
>> you know
your trousers falling down in public looks bad, dude. It's like
it's not a it's not like oh you're a now actually. Yeah, you
you do the exact same type of as me. You do the same type of
as me. >> No, it's not even close. It's not even on the
same scale. It's not even worth comparing. If you compare it,
you're >> Well, this conversation started with me saying
the comparison is to Tom Foolery, >> Yeah. And then what
happened after that, Becca? We went through that and then and
>> you asked me where the comparisons can lie with Destiny.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I said
Willie Mac wants the comparison to be about Destiny and you said
well I think there is a comparison there. You said you said that
and then I asked >> uh I don't still want to dog right
now. He's already arguing with him. I'm not saying that I'm not
saying
I'm saying that the claim that like okay for example like a general
claim against Destiny is that Destiny ends up in relationships
with like BPD women um and essentially takes advantage of people
in vulnerable situations. Now, I'm not saying that Just Dilk
did that, but I'm saying that if people wanted to make that a
comparison using Cherry, given Cher's history with Destiny and
these very similar, insane tweets that have come out from Cherry
about just milk and then they then you can then you can make
that comparison, can't you? Isn't that isn't that a comparison
that's like, you know, just going, "Oh, these things are similar
to this thing. Seems like a very reasonable comparison to make."
>> I think is >> Hold on, hold on. Can I just ask,
do you think um do you think I was the same critical in the same
way of Destiny when I was aware of one or two times he did
Like like obviously I knew that he had been in relationship with
people with like BPD or some mental illness, right? I knew that
beforehand
before any of this came out. It was maybe like having these really
bad allegations coming out and then re-examining past behavior
and seeing this like very persistent pattern over time. >> Yeah,
we did this pattern of behavior and Yeah. Yeah. So, like I think
that is by far the bigger criticism of Destiny. I don't think
anybody's saying is that what you're going, "Oh, no, you can
never ever somebody who's mentally ill." That's just really >> Well,
I I Okay, again, I never said that. But I do. >> Yeah,
sure. But I mean, that's a that's one of the narratives that
the thing you're talking about when that came out that was pushed
by Destiny and amplified by Willie, but it's I understand you
don't think that >> Becca doesn't agree with that full
thing. Basically, Becket's argument is um well, you know, bias
exists. >> Or that it was imprudent to
that's that's the case in some way. >> Yeah. My argument
is it's up the case in some way.
>> Um and I think that >> in what way? Like in a
public perception >> In a in a public perception way. Yeah.
So I will say it has probably done that because other people
will say that like something's tainted or but that it's only
people who have like an interest in doing that and then we can
point to that and say well there are a lot of people have an
interest in like using this to try to discredit something but
actually materially there's no difference to the case whatsoever.
>> It's it's not it's noted up the case right it some there
are some people that might have had some doubt swed in their
mind by or might have you know some small amount of people might
have flipped. Stop up the case. It's like excepting the framing
of up the case. >> Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. Most people
agree at what happened here. >> Hey, look. Live debate
coaching. That's always nice. >> Okay. Yeah. You legit,
honestly, Stardust is actually going to make 50 tweets. A 50
tweet thread.
>> I, by the way, I joined after the fact. I'm totally
fine. I'm totally fine talking. Just clearly mad about how this
went earlier, right? >> A total debate. I'm trying to rape
back it right now. Listen, listen. You can I'm gonna make the
exact same points.
>> I think the only tangible argument you could have here
is that this hurts my reputation. I don't think it hurts any
kind of case. I don't think the cops would give one tiny [__]
about this, >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. I I And we are talking
about the public perfection uh perception here. I do think >> Okay.
Well, then I mean probably perception instead of the case would
be appropriate wording. >> Sure. Okay. So, >> those
are my words to be fair. I
>> Okay. That is just to be clear that isn't quite what
you were saying earlier, Becky. You were saying there was a comparison
to Destiny. You were that is what you said. You were not just
say that's just public perception. >> I've just I've literally
shouted at you the previous one. There is a comparison to Destiny.
There is an easy comparison with Destiny where you've both got
Cher's tweets at Destiny with the came 17 times versus two and
the insane [__] that came out after the party where
like she felt isolated to the tweets that came out about Just
Silk and like how that relationship looked in the public eye.
That's an obvious comparison point.
>> Sure. Yeah, I just give you that.
>> Okay. So, you've got somebody who Destiny has a previous
long-running drama in relationships with over a significant period
of time. >> Sure. I should be I should actually be really
specific. Like the uh the allegations are like slightly different,
but in terms of how people are going to read those tweets and
judge me, I think it's probably like I don't really care. >> Yeah,
sure. And I mean, >> hold on, hold on, Cherry. It's uh
he's talking about Sorry, Cherry's in my chat. He's talking about
like with the allegations from before the crimes came out. Obviously,
the the analogy wouldn't be after.
So I think it would be basically you're saying that Cherry had
tweeted about Destiny's some of his behavior beforehand, tweeted
about some of my behavior and that's analogous. Not that I'm
analogous to the crimes Dest
I should be very clear. I'm not accusing Just Dulk of being a
or of recording people without their consent. >> The crime
committed back saying >> No, I'm saying that this may be
the public perception of crimes. Uh I don't I don't know. I don't
think I've ever called Destiny. I'm just saying that that is
a word that's thrown around >> Would you consider saying
it? Would you consider calling Destiny for us right >> Don't
do the [__] Connor thing with me, buddy. Okay. Okay.
We're not retreading that hellscape of a conversation. Uh no,
I wouldn't I wouldn't say that Destiny is a from what I've seen.
Um
because I don't think that I I don't I don't think I'd water
that by deception. Uh, I think you have to be very very careful
about what that looks like and what that and the way that's >> Okay,
I'm going to stop. >> Okay, thank you. >> Would you
uh >> do you think do you think you should be able to be
measured by your own standard? Like if Destiny was making by
deception arguments, would would it be reasonable to measure
him by that >> I think that >> we're just going to
we're going to get too far off. Don't answer that question. >> No,
just just very quickly because I think that I think that judging
people by their own standards is like a big part of the conversation
we've been having all morning. So, I think there are potentials
there where you can have arguments about people's standards.
Destiny doesn't have any. Let's be clear. That's again, that's
a big part of this conversation, right? Destiny doesn't care
about Dark Sing. He doesn't give a he never has. This was my
argument against Destiny like three years ago when the egg girl
thing happened. So, I don't know.
I don't really give a about that position. Destiny has no standards
and constantly breaches whatever previous um positions he's brought
up. and then DGG sweeps for it. I I don't think that's even a
contra well that's a controversial position if you say it to
anyone in DGG. Right.
>> All right.
>> But so with if you want to know what I uh go you go.
>> Yeah. Go on. Go on. Go on. No, no, no, no. I've spoken
enough. Go on. >> No, I actually I want you to finish with
your your points.
>> Okay. So, I was going to say, I mean, when this all
started, there were the conversations about people knowing things
and sweeping like this was accusations thrown at like Erodite
and Nick. Nick came on your stream to talk about it. But obviously,
like when Nick took his position, it was based on the evidence
there and I have a position against the fact that Destiny has
done that. I'm cutting ties. Uh, Erdike took
>> Yeah. Yeah. And then Erodite had a position of if you
cross this line then I'll break contact she's now back working
with him and you had a position of well here's my hard line but
that hard line again is personal. It's not a hard line and and
as more information has come out it looks more and more personal
as opposed to well Destiny does bad things against people. Again,
I'm just talking about the impression here, which is going to
be like, well, okay, how much do you listen to a person who essentially
just cares about their friend, not about any of the wider moral
>> Wait, I mean, I obviously cared about the wider moral
implications. Like, I obviously told Pixie, "Hey, if you need
a platform to like discuss this on or announce this on, like
I would be willing, right, like months before, I think way before
the Sunday thing." >> Like, I obviously cared. >> I
like I cared. It was just like I'm not going to I was in essentially
a similar position to Dorman, right? Where I I knew like the
pixie thing for I felt like I was fairly confident in the pixie
thing. Molina was saying she wasn't going to do anything and
it's like well I'm kind of like holding my until somebody decides
they're going public and like making a public accusation and
like doing something right. I felt like I think a lot of us were
in the same place where we had the same information. We didn't
know for sure it was happening and we were just like, "Yeah,
well it's probably non-consensual, but can't say for sure. I
guess we're just waiting, right? The the personal thing was that
made me like personally upset, but I said as much, right? I said
as much that like obviously I've been streaming with this person
for a long time. I had been streaming with them for a long time.
Uh they were extremely like an extremely good and close friend
of mine and that's what upset me. Like that's what made me like
vitriolic towards them, right? Instead of sort of dispassionately
analyzing it. But I think it was incredibly open about that from
like the first hop. Uh Wes came onto my stream like the maybe
January 22nd or 23rd and was like, "You're just you're mad about
like the cherry thing most of all, right?" And I was like, "Yeah,
Destiny's a fler." And Destiny tried to mass report my channel
for that. But like the the bias was just that that we were friends
and I announced that bias and was open about it from the beginning.
That was probably the thing I got asked about like the most if
I was ever debating people on it. They're like, "Do you think
you can really analyze this?" Like, and it comes down to the
same point every time. Just give me the take, right? Just give
me the take that's wrong and we can debate the take.
Saying I'm biased is fine. I don't really care if you don't want
to listen to me. That's fine. But just give me the take that
was wrong. But nobody nobody actually does that. So I don't know.
As far as I'm as far as I'm concerned, if somebody had a problem
with my takes or my analysis, they could point out problems with
it. And I haven't gotten that yet. Yeah. Well, I suppose I I
suppose I suppose my biggest issue is the fact that this was
obviously
>> like if you're just friends with Cherry and you've kind
of got that biased take, I can see that kind of being deflected.
>> But by the point that Cherry comes out and starts talking
about having a relationship with you.
>> Do you see how that's a much stronger line to take against
you than anything
>> Okay. So when that So because we don't have a clear
picture of what the
>> Did you not both realize that that was indeed strong
possibility? >> Cherry said or not. >> Well, I don't
know whether I trust what Cherry said. It was some of it was
quite vague. Some of it was like I've been in love with him for
a year. Do I trust the fact that she was in love with you for
a year and never told you and you had no idea? I mean, I'll be
honest, not
>> Uh I never claimed that.
Like obvious
but like I had made it very clear like married no married no
not interested in any way. >> Okay. So but once you breached
that point do you do you not think that you know that became
public? Were you not thinking at the time if this becomes public
this is going to you know do huge amounts of potential damage
to both of us?
Um, I think at the time I was like, "Oh,
so I think I didn't want to make it public." The thing we discussed,
right, right away, I was like, "Oh, we should we should like
make sure we this actually works in some way." And then like
I was ready to go. >> Probably around the time it ended
up going public was about the time I'd be ready to go public.
And ultimately, like I was just willing if people were like,
"Oh, if people decided, oh, you guys have been like dating forever
and actually this is why you freaked out, I'm fine with that,
right? I'm not gonna like change my life or >> Did you
mean what you said in the DM? The the fact that you would have
ended your streaming career of it being with >> Um
that I don't think anybody said that or I said that.
>> Okay. Maybe maybe that's >> I I thought something
was said that implied that. I could be misremembering. >> I
think it was I think it was something about me like deleting
my [__] and I don't know. I don't know when that
was said precisely.
>> That in essence means the same thing,
>> It wasn't Sorry. Sorry. No, no, no. It was it was like
it was it was like apppropo of nothing. Like as in like ah this
is such I should just delete all of this
was like how I remember it happening. But like >> it wasn't
like a serious consideration. >> It wasn't like a serious
thing that we were doing though that I was thinking about. No.
>> Okay. I mean for me
the comparisons to Tom have always been stronger. >> Hold
on. Hold on. It was like the opposite though. It was like oh
like if this blows up I I would just walk away from all of this.
It was like it was like that. It wasn't um to be together. I'm
gonna end this. That wasn't We never had any problem being together
and having the streaming career going. >> Okay. So, if
it So, that's why I'm asking you. So, was this something where
you were like, "Cherry matters more to me than the streaming
career does. So, if everything blows up, I'll walk away from
it." >> Um, it was I mean, it wasn't something thought
of like that, but I was aware it could make things difficult.
But in my mind, like it could make things difficult, but it's
like, "Oh, I just need to like be persistent. It might set me
back slightly." But I never once thought it was going to like
cost me my career. was never once concerned about that. If if
literally recording people non-consensually and distributing
those recordings non-conensually can't end your career, how the
[__] would this end my career? >> Oh, sure.
You can stream through anything, right?
>> Yeah. That was never like a thing I was concerned about
or thought. >> Go. No, I was going to say like uh from
a st this is like totally irrelevant from a standpoint of concern
like I wouldn't have used that as like your frame of reference
because obviously Destiny just has like a way more like a way
larger pre-established dedicated fan base that's going to like
continue to attempt to like justify their position as fans of
his by negating >> Yeah, but no one gets wiped out by any
[__] like that. It's not just Destiny. It's like
unless you totally freak the [__] out. And like I
don't want to talk about howed up people are in general, but
if anything, my average viewership went up significantly after
that. So people are [__] up. >> Yeah, people
know you. That's >> honestly people are justed up. Like
I it's it's honestly
it's just a it's a weird fact. >> You have to demonstrate
value in streaming otherwise you don't get
>> so stupid. God, >> that's why Quinn's struggling.
I'm still trying to figure out how Aiden has more viewers than
me. >> He's funnier. >> Self admitted Vol. Well,
>> yeah. I hate to say this, like if so Willie Mack was
the one that put out a lot of this like kind of distrust JTO
stuff based on who he's dating. Hasn't he basically just done
anti-Palestine
supporter pieces for years?
>> Like I I know that like there's stuff out there, right?
I get it. But it's out there now. Like, should we not just say
that Willie might have a further bias?
>> Oh, yo. Yo. Yeah. Actually, wait. Hold the hold up for
a second, Beck. No, this is a good point. Becca, why don't you
hold the stand for Willy, Mac? >> I I don't I I'm asking
him to clarify. I don't I don't know what you mean. >> Well,
okay. So, >> you don't know what anyone >> Here,
let me do this. Uh, so you you've watched some of his Assan videos,
right? >> No. Well, I mean,
this has happened. >> Okay. Well, that's fine. So, you
know >> I don't give a about Hassan. So, >> I understand.
So, you understand what Dan Saltman's critiques of Sassan are,
>> Like he's a terrorist sympathizer, like all that. >> Anti-Israel.
He's he doesn't like much. >> Yeah. Anti-Israel and all
that. Willie Mack is basically trotting out the same Houthies
coming on the ship thing. shouting out the same, hey, before
we define them as a terrorist organization, he had a supposed
Houthy person on his stream to criticize him as an Israel like
hater and stuff. Willie Mack does have a bias.
He does have a bias based on the relationship that >> I
disow this by the way. I completely disavow this. I completely
any of this. >> It's fine. Again, I'm just saying like
if we're going to be saying your our opinions are based on >> I'm
not streaming right now. I'm not rebroadcasting this information.
This isn't on me. >> Okay. Yeah. I don't want to get you
in trouble with your people. So, >> wait. J is No. >> Oh,
not again, mate. >> Streaming this, you know. >> This
is enough. >> Jump back at streaming this. >> I'm
already on every list he could put me on. It's fine. >> Yeah.
I don't really care. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Wait, if it was Wait, if it was important for
Jtock to disclose the Cherry relations due to some potential
conflict of interest, can you argue that he should have That's
what I'm saying. >> Wait, that's what he just said. You
>> realize what you were talking about, >> dude.
Aiden, again, again, that has not been my argument. My argument
is consistently ending up in a relationship with somebody you
are currently doing like coverage of and and have been like earmarked
as whether intentionally or otherwise the point of contact for
the person carrying those accusations into the public um and
ending up into in a relationship with them. It's a very specific
standard, Becca. It's a very specific standard. >> Well,
that's fine. But you asked me what my standard was. And in >> this
exact case, I actually have a standard for this. Okay, >> hold
on. Don't hold on. I have this standard constantly and again
I don't
just so you're like aware, Becket, like obviously this happened
this happened how long ago? This happened like about a month
ago and then it was maybe 3 or 4 weeks that we were like chatting
in this way at all. And this was almost immediately a thing of
like, oh, this is complex like how we're going to handle this
if we if we try something like this. Right. Like I I understand
it's not really like humans going to human isn't exactly like
a great defense, but it's like yeah I like it was like oh this
is going to be complex like talking about this and when we go
public >> and it was like really early on sorry that's
how Chud put it. So uh really early on we decided that like we're
probably going to disclose this almost
>> Well I'm assuming not in the way that you it ended up
being disclosed.
>> Uh no but like probably around that time
uh the way it got it got disclosed like
uh it like it is what it is. Um that's not like a dealbreaker
for me. So care about that person. So yeah, it is what it is.
But even if it had come out even if it had come out not that
way, I still think the same people who are spinning it this way
would have tried to spin it this way. Would have been less successful
by a lot, but it it like it would have been spun this way no
matter what. So it was something we're going to have to deal
with no matter what.
>> Yeah. I mean I don't disagree with you. I think that
at a core part I think there is an element where it's like well
yeah sure humans hum human's going to human
but >> well I'm sorry I'm saying that it was like it was
complicated
and I didn't necessarily want it disclosed the way it was but
like I was always planning to disclose it pretty quickly and
like realistically the person who would be most affected I guess
by the public perception of this and it being affected negatively
was somebody who is very much consenting to this relationship.
So, I don't know. Is there like a third party we forgot to ask?
>> Becca just uh thinks, you know, he's just like constantly
gonna restate what happened and say that it's wrong and not >> Well,
no, I think I have explained like >> so I'm just I'm asking
who is who is harmed here that can't consent to that that like
couldn't have had that conversation and is incapable of making
that decision.
>> The audience. You think I wanted to know about your
live? >> Okay. I think there's an element there where when
you >> we have you have to argue that Cherry is too diminished
in capacity to consent. That's what you have to argue. So, are
you ready to argue that right now? >> About I don't think
it's I don't think it's about diminished capacity.
I think it's about the fact that
you must recognize the fact that that was going to potentially
do damage and be used against both of you, right? >> Uh
I we both recognize that. >> How many times say yes obviously
it would be used. >> So, yes. So, I'm just curious. Can
I just ask you before you continue? Why did you ask that question
when I actually just spent the past 5 minutes explaining that
exact concept?
>> Okay. So, but that's my criticism. It's like an incredibly
thing to do. >> And these are like you
didn't come out to do I think JTalk is evil. The question came
out to are the things that are being said about JTO obvious snipes
that are going to happen from Willie and Destiny and people who
we can both agree. We can both agree to cross the road without
looking both ways. And you know, there's a very good chance that
if you cross the road without looking both ways, you'll get hit
by a car. And would we say it's wrong
to cross the road without looking both ways? >> Hold on.
Hold on a second. My original point here with >> You said
it was wrong. You said it. You said it was wrong like six times.
I've asked you said it was right. You said it was wrong. You
said it was the wrong thing to do. >> Uh yeah, it is the
wrong thing today. >> Is it wrong and bad? I asked you.
I said I understand. I understand it. Bad public perception.
Is it wrong? Is it bad? And you said yes. Yes. Yeah. I think
that if just position was I care about Cherry and Cher's well-being
is my priority, then there should have been cuz I don't know
what this looks like. I don't know what the Sorry. I don't know
what the reality is. I only know what this looks like and the
real and what it looks like is you didn't fully account for how
potentially damaging this could be and then
kind of ended up putting both of you in that position. Now maybe
that is >> she not have the ability to account for that
risk though herself if it's gonna be her >> at the same
time like and I hate to point this out like this all came out
through tweets of like just apparently like her having a massive
crash out over it and just her friend has known her for a long
time knows that Cherry has her own issues to deal with and then
that crash out does happen right
>> do you think I hold Who? So are confused. Who's the
harm party in this
>> for both of you?
>> And also the overall kind of arguments against like
Destiny, right?
>> Why do you think this affects Pixie's case somehow?
>> I don't think it helps Pixie's case.
>> Okay, that's I Okay, >> so it doesn't affect me.
Okay. Me going and eating cheese. Does me eating cheeseburger
help Pixie's case? Does it If I eat cheeseburger, does that help
Pixiey's case?
>> I think you'd be I I think you'd be more amanable as
sort of jolly and fat. But
>> but you know how Destiny works. You
>> talk. He could be a How would that hurt? >> Actually,
hold on, hold on, hold on. Destiny builds his defenses
by block byb block discrediting detractors. That's how Destiny
works, right?
>> Okay. So, you have handed Destiny a block with which
to
make an attack against >> Anytime I say the word Kiwi Farms,
I'm handing Destiny a block with which to claim that he should
be [__] rap.
Stop doing it. Dude, totally disavowing any doxing or anything
on Kiwi Farms did nothing to prevent this guy from trying to
dox me and trying to like say I should be right. Like even if
I don't handle blocks, he still just makes up. He makes up about
everybody. Like if he doesn't have the block, he just makes up
and people still replatform it like Willy. Okay. When he replat
when he just says, "Oh, Lav and Kelly were running revenge porn
discords about me." And he's like, "Oh, well, I guess I'll just
I guess I'll just publish that." >> Are they in there?
point that Beth was trying to make is does this actually change
anyone's mind? Was there any anyone who was leaning towards believing
this believing this before that now disbelieves it because of
this revelation? >> Um I would say probably yes.
Now is that based on like is that based on what the like the
facts of the matter changing? No. But it is public perception
and I think I think for me and Cherry when we had this discussion,
we both understood that that could be like a thing that
You're right to you're right to focus on on Pixie though because
I mean no disrespect to her. She was like a secondary character
in the Destiny allegations.
Like layer one of the iceberg is Pixie. And if you dig a bit
deeper, you find out about Cherry,
>> So, you would have to know that second layer and start
to know more for that change in public perception to even affect
you. Right. >> What? I don't understand why any of this
>> that second layer is so true.
>> I think you would have to already have a good amount
of knowledge to even know about the cherry alg. >> No,
you No, you wouldn't. It's it's it was like both of these things
were often presented in cotandem to one another. >> Is
there a video that the cherry allegations aren't mentioned in
>> that I'm
Willie M just kind of glazed over them. Like if you want to go
with that like Willie Mac didn't you know he just said like in
the first video right >> sorry Razie >> no I sorry
I think like Willie Mac's first video he said what five total
seconds of Cher's thing right so it's like yeah it's like right
>> I think it was more than that >> I I don't think
a little more than that I just think he missed the pattern of
behavior and that's what I was trying to that's what I poorly
articulated >> I mean that's what I told him in DMs yeah
that's why I told him in DMs when I gave him my documents so
it's like yeah >> we going saying that yeah why Will he
make like gay? Can we get off the the the like running around
in circles trying to get Becca to say something? I'm I'm bored
now. Okay. But my point is that Okay. And again, no disrespect
to Cherry, but how many hours of content do you think has been
spent talking about Pixie and Pixie allegations? And how many
do you think have been spent uh talking about Cherry? >> Well,
I've spent way more time on Pixie allegations because Pixie public
legal documents that are good content.
>> Yeah. But also, do you think the wider sphere? Because
I'm talking about broadly the amount of people who've changed
their minds because of this revelation. I don't think it's changed
the dial that much. >> I think Wait, do you think more
people change their minds because of this quote unquote revelation
or because of Destiny talking about implied consent and then
leaking things that apparently happened in this court transcript
that he frames his wins. >> He like frames his wins, but
they aren't actually wins. They're just things that were in previous
documents from like weeks ago. Like unfortunately, Destiny can
just make things up and he can just change way more minds than
even
at all. >> Are you asking if it changes it does change
the perception, but I don't know. So, do you think because that
could happen that I shouldn't pursue this relationship? Is that
your argument? >> No. No. To be clear, my point here is
that it it doesn't change it meaningfully. People who already
believed destiny already believe.
>> People who believe you already believe you, right? Cherry
is like a secondary character in all of this.
>> Her allegations doesn't change the the wins that much.
Would people really make that argument but >> and believe
in cherries.
>> I think this is used by Destiny in a in a similar way
to everything else where he's like this is proof that nobody
who is making who's accusing me of this is good faith. He's been
saying that the whole time and this is the only thing that like
is a fact. This is one of the only things that actually happened.
whether or not it like should make him more believable. Obviously,
it shouldn't, right? >> But this is uh this is one of the
only things that's actually happened. So, I think he'll use it
in the same way and more people might be swayed. But I think
those people weren't really basing anything on facts anyway.
And like you were always going to be they were always just waiting
for a reason to go back to Destiny, go back to watching him.
>> I think I think this is one of the things that doesn't
actually sway anybody. It just strengthens the resolve of people
who really like disbelieve the
>> yeah. I could see that too. Sure. >> Yeah. Wow.
There you go. >> I'm glad we got to vom that guys.
>> Okay, so Willie Mack is a gay. We all agree.
We agree. >> Uh, waterbrained vacuous basic sloppy.
>> I think he's immortal. >> I like sloppy. >> I
think
I could sue Willie Mac for
>> I'm looking into this right now. I'm contacting Techone.
Contacting Cameron
>> Speaking of Techone, did you guys see that Aerodite
interview Techone? I'm obsessed with Aerodite. Okay.
>> I'm obsessed with I mean >> I'm lesser
at this point. You are you are more obsessed with Arerodite than
me. >> Am I?
>> dude. Unfortunately, the content is just super funny.
>> A bunch of harassers and who's who's disparaging Harry?
>> Oh, probably me. >> Probably me.
>> he wants
>> you'll talk to him. >> Probably not. Oh, okay.
>> Okay. I'll add to Okay. Okay. We good. We wrapped with
that. That's That's fine. Everyone Everyone displeased and miserable.
Fantastic.
>> Well,
just to like cap it off.
>> Do you think Well, okay. No, never mind. >> All
right. No, go ahead. Go on.
>> It's fine. I just went
>> famed JT stalking. That' be nice. You know, that'd be
that'd be tasty. Go ahead, buddy. He's >> not the first
time he's defamed me, by the way. >> Yeah, I mean I said
earlier
I think hold on me. I said this earlier. Yes. Quote tweeting
you and saying that just retweeting you and retweeting his docs
is like 10 layers deep and crazy and the real problem like being
at Destiny or throwaway or whatever. Yeah, I think I think I
understand Willy's annoyance because of the information that's
presented in the same way I'd be understanding of anyone who
had information presented that way. But obviously that wasn't
your intention and it wasn't just oaks either. Okay. Yeah. You
happy?
>> Yeah, I'm I'm fine with that.
>> Was that Was that short enough? Is that >> Call
wheat.
>> Misconduct. Anyway, hey guys, what's up? Um, it's me.
Uh, thanks for letting me on, you know, Beckets because I I did
want to point out obviously you guys are making fun of Willie
Mack for like freaking out, spreading out calling Jto a
uh a dock or whatever, which I feel is unfounded. I don't know
what conclusion you guys came to, but at the same time, you're
more than happy to facilitate a pathetic impotent liar on the
call uh in in the form of Resir who just lies about my community
and me cuz he's mad that I made fun of his fat gay girlfriend.
Well, wait. Do I Do you think it's unfair that I call Spinal
BJ a Jason
>> No. I think it's unfair to say harassing community and
have bad journalism. You're not engaging with me. Answer my >> I'm
not answering your questions. >> Yeah. All right. Well,
why don't you just go eat yummy
>> You see, but you're actually standing me. But now you
want to be like
care about me. Don't care for me. Next. >> What's your
bench, you maggot? >> What's my question? I think it's
like am I harassment? Yes or no? Right now. >> Yeah. The
topic is very clear. The topic is res. Why are you such a coward
that you won't engage with the fact that you called me harassment
community and said I have bad journalism and I said you're going
to be like oh you're a gay malt teaser because you're coward.
>> I've already because one I've already >> you've
already talked about this in your own gay.
>> if you're going to make those points >> literal
fake country. Okay. Literally I talk to you. Whenever you say
this, you're running
>> You malt freak. I talked to you in private
tal you was there. Bug Swander was there and I said >> that
was a private VC. It was referring
you [__]
patty moddy. All right. Get your fat fingers out of your real
quick. I know that you're a little over >> You've seen
my face. >> I need you. >> You've seen your face.
You've seen my >> I've seen your face. Yes. And now I'm
calling you fat, man. I'm fat. I can call you fat, dude. I can
call J. >> You can lie. You can lie. >> You can focus
on >> Sorry, man. Hey, being you can just lie about me
being and like meme out of it. >> Things because again
in that private call I specifically told you what that you don't
have a good standard of evidence and then you proceed to do the
exact same thing after that. >> No, you didn't say that
in the call. I have the call recorded. Why double time in the
>> recording the spicy chat call where I wasn't a spicy
chat call >> where I specifically told you I specifically
told you in the spicy chat call that I had with bug swander I
specifically told you that that tech tone guy that tech person
not tech tone that tech person that you had on was messaging
a bunch of random people in my community so you got a half story
right >> yeah tech I don't even remember who he was he's
just some fat like >> I don't think I talked to you about
tech >> Oh no we did We did. We did talk about in spicy.
Bug Squander was there. Yeah, we did sit. >> Was I there?
You know, I'm a bug. >> You were there. I talked directly
to you. Do I go sit in Spicy very often,
>> I wouldn't know. I The times are >> I mean, I
don't know. I talk to you about I see you in there how often,
you little freak. >> All right, stop acting like it's a
great place without you. But no, it's always
>> for years, Perry. I know, buddy.
>> For years, I haven't hung out for icy chat, buddy. >> Right.
So I don't think you were there. I don't think that the situation
I was there tell you about this. >> I remember um I remember
Spor talking to me about this. I remember Doug Brain talking
about this. I just don't remember talking about this. >> Well
that's great
idea. >> Get your together and figure out
what's your point then your point now I am I wasn't the only
one that told you about this. So multiple people told you about
this. Therefore there's a pattern. >> You the bringer.
Yeah. You're gay little
>> Your gay feeder dynamic told me about >> eater
dynamic thing. That's great. I know that you got dynamic with
I understand. I get why you're mad at me. It's fine. Don't worry.
>> Oh, I the one with the dynamic
grandmother
grandmother and you want you to have
forget you do it all over again.
You are cowards
saying that you know you're going to
>> you wanted to see >> moderation. I think we need
to
you don't know how to moderate. >> Yeah. So Harry saying
resi accused him of having a harassment community. What >> and
also bad journalistic standards and he said I talked about it
with him which I don't get but whatever. >> Just remake
the argument then.
Roosevelt make the make the argument that Perry has a harassment
community and bad jealousy standards is here. >> Uh the
response to me saying that Perry has a harassment community is
that shortly after I have many people that came in including
Starbase, one of his
after timeline is wrong
Kyle. So basically when you had Starbase coming in calling me
a and then 10 days later he gets revealed to basically be doing
a little bit of sketchy stuff as well as being the you know infamous
pest uh paragon. Right. Yeah. I'm going to kind of draw some
through lines. I'm going to draw some through lines when your
community, Spinal BJ, and others are revealed to have a Lollcon
sharing server with miners in it. The same way you did exactly
to Marcus,
>> right? You were dancing on his rights.
>> And then the bad journalist
moderator allow one time. Let's go one time.
>> This is the dog.
Moderator moderator. Let's go. Yeah. One allegation at a time.
>> Yeah. Well, I I was just laying it all out because he
told me to lay it all out. So, yeah, if you want the journalistic
standards part, it's literally like I told you, hey, you should
probably, you know, reach around and figure out what's going
on because yeah, that tech guy that you brought on that did freak
out about because he was sending her increasingly crazy
uh was messaging a bunch of people in my community. So, when
I streamed it, I got to find out about that. >> And you
could have just asked me
around.
>> All right. Well, I can respond to all that now. So yeah,
did did >> as far as the shut up [__] shut
up. Shut up. Shut up.
>> Shut up.
>> Let's have Perry respond to the first allegation. Okay.
The harassment community. So, what say you? >> Right. It's
just completely incorrect to say that you said I have harassment
community and then Starbase showed up. Starve, first of all,
I don't control Starbase doesn't part of it. I know. >> Are
you not going to let me respond? You're not going to be finished.
Cool. But listen, this happened. First of all, they didn't come
to your chat to harass. They just said like, "Oh, what are you
talking about?" And then you were like, "We're weird to them."
which is fair enough. I mean, they are like a weird bloody freak,
but the idea is that's my community. You blame BXKS on being
my community, even though that's like some that goes around the
>> address here. Don't don't just start spazzing out other
stuff. Address points made here. So, >> showed up and then
10 days later.
>> I think I think already says he's drawing through lines.
He's saying, "I I'm interpreting that you have harassment community
because your top moderator came and accused me of being a
uh projecting potentially
chatters who also engage in the same behavior." And >> yeah,
like BXKS, that's why I'm pointing out those aren't my >> And
like BXKS made several accounts to do such a thing. >> But
but Bronx No, Bronx
has several accounts. That's That's Bronx. Okay. >> I bought
that guy from my account.
from my channel. >> Yeah, you don't know. You don't know
>> This guy li
real quick. Real quick. Have you seen those messages? They literally
came in speaking specifically about you and why
>> obviously they're going to talk about me. Doesn't make
them my chat or >> Yeah, but but the thing is if everybody
comes in and they just say it annoys you. Yeah. people want to
annoy you and by doing annoy you
stickers the next pause I'm interjecting okay resi I have a question
for you all the people we've just described here BXS
uh starbased uh who was the other one spinal BJ >> spinal
but he's like a >> you can find them yeah well no but all
three of them you can also find
well before star or whatever you can find them chat yeah you
can find them in queen's chat you can find May I respond to that
real? I understand what you're saying. At no point has there
ever been a time where somebody's come into my chat who is not
a regular in my discord or regular in my chat to mention Queen
talking about me. It is literally never been chatters. It's never
been Chud's chatters. It's never been your chatters Aiden. It's
never been Beckett's chatters. It's Perry's chatters. And they
identify themselves as such.
>> They don't. BX case doesn't identify itself as a Perry
chatter.
>> So what's the logic here? talk about
annoys you >> and that's my fault. >> Annoys me.
Yes, it does. It does annoy >> That's my fault. How is
it my fault that people talk about me annoys you whereas talking
about doesn't annoy >> is it? Did I ever say that it was
your fault or that I don't >> Well, you say I have an community
on me. >> Yeah,
I I specifically said I don't think Perry is doing any of these
things. I know because you've watched all my [__]
streams. I know. It's okay, bud. But here's the thing. I every
single time mention Perry himself doesn't engage in lollycon
behavior. He >> Well, not every single time. You're just
me once. >> Every single time, Perry. I do. >> No,
not really. >> I always watch them or not. You don't always
make vague allegations that I'm And then >> I make vague
allegations you associate not doing. >> I make vague allegations
you associate with the same thing that you >> And you don't
every single time say, "Well, he doesn't actually associate with
the one you tried to steal Kyle from, Perry. I make the same
vague >> Are you really going to cry about people calling
you a
>> Perry? Isn't your stream content literally defaming
people and threatening to rap them? >> Yeah. Like I'm just
sorry, man. Like >> it's very clear that I don't mean what
I said. I'm not >> And there's a difference between me
stating things. There's a difference between me stating things.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> Wait, what? >> It's like very clear. When you
need something,
>> one of those things is beyond the point. One of those
things get you blacklisted
me talking.
>> I didn't call Perry. >> I said that he's surrounded
by them.
>> Okay. When you when you said that Perry was surrounded
by, did you did you mean
>> You mean that? Yeah.
>> Amazing contribution. Listen,
it's a very clear difference
versus telling my audience to go out harass people. Obviously,
you're allowed to insult people on the internet. You're not It's
usually seen as
harassment just surprisingly never know about to do their legacous
behavior. They just make another discord and then you surpris
never know about any of this, right, >> I wasn't in the
server. So, you weren't in the server. Ask me if I didn't know.
You just luckily >> I don't follow this guy. Why would
I give a [__] >> Out of sight, out of mind.
Right, Perry? >> That was it was like even my chatter.
I think he's like,
>> so you don't call him a harassment or pedal community.
>> You just spur out about me cuz you're mad at me. Well,
he already addressed that argument. >> Okay. Wait, so so
Perry, you think Resir is mad at you? What do you think Res is
mad at you about? >> Um that I made fun of his um fat girlfriend.
I brought CPCA on and we talked about him being a feeder with
honest. I've literally not seen that. Uh I'm not
like I want to be clear. I'm not >> So it must be the ICO
thing. It must be when I brought on >> real quick. >> No,
you just lie about embarrassing >> real quick. Real quick.
I find zero value in interacting with
>> There's a difference.
>> Yeah. You're above everything. You're above commentary.
You're above talking about you just talk about all that's why
you spent all this time making this uh state of play that's just
a a copy of my state of play is because you're so above this
state of play was like oh he looks like a fat and literally all
I have to do with you >> that was funny yours is boring
and you just lied in yours and so biased I agree >> guys
I am sharing the thing uh as you can see here in my chart as
gay >> yeah after being forced by chatter after chatter
to talk about you wanted first you deleted
then You want to fuckle forced by chatter after chatter. Wait,
didn't Parry deny having a malicious brigading fan base? >> Well,
it wasn't my chatter. It wasn't my >> Oh, it wasn't his
chatters all of a sudden. Yes, there we go. It's like
out of mind. Out of mind,
>> guys. It wasn't Perry. It was Gary. It wasn't Perry.
It was Green Gary. Guys, come on. Twins, right? They're twins.
They're both fat. They're both useless. They both come from a
country. Yes.
>> Have you seen your house, man? How am I the useless
one? You're so useless. Your grandmother doesn't even remember
what you did. Maybe that's the dementia. Point being Point being.
>> Yeah. No, it wasn't the Shut up. >> It was the
It was the stroke that I'm like assisting. >> It was the
trauma. It was the trauma of watching you have. Point being,
it's very clear to me. Okay. If it's not the me making fun of,
it must be me bringing Aiko on and agreeing with them about your
gay transphobia argument. Cuz ever since that point, you've just
been like spuring out about me. Even though you say you don't
care, you just talk about me all the time accidentally. I guess
it's like very embarrassing stuff. >> I bring up the fact
that your chosen one >> you're also above it all. I guess
I don't care. Bring it up all the time. >> Your chosen
one, Perry, is an AG
chosen one architect, but whatever. Just lie about what I said
and then spur out about it. Sure. >> Who you been hanging
about with, man? >> Hang I don't hang out with Spinal private,
so I don't know where you got this idea from. I'm as much of
a friend of Spinal as Logic is. You don't go out against literally
your chosen one. You see a connection is literally your chosen
one. The moment you found out he was running a lolly server with
Myers in it, you don't say that anymore. >> You're running
I've stopped saying that but it's not being funny
because it stopped being funny because it sounds like you're
agreeing with a right. That's why
for months I've
disgusting Twitter account. You wanted to you wanted to [__]
>> I was saying I was saying the split between you and
Parry has probably been after the Starbase stuff to be fair
after the after
split with spinal >> to be clear
that
the DMs with me.
>> Hi. Hi. I'm here. So again, to be clear, it was after
the echo stuff when I realized that I gained no pleasure from
interacting with you. I gained no benefit from interacting with
you. And I don't like you,
>> Harry. You made fun of me. I don't like you anymore.
You're a harasser now. That's what you said out loud. That's
>> Yeah. Well, might not have the ability
interact with or not or no. >> Feels like it's about the
IO stuff. So what what happened to the IEO stuff? What's the
problem with the IEO stuff?
>> I think it's because I wasn't an unbiased moderator.
I had a particular side and Reserv was upset at that. I'm pretty
sure. I'm not sure. He never really hashed out me in DMC. He
said, "It's all content, Barry. It's all content." And then he
deleted all those DMs. So, >> yeah, that's Yeah. What's
the issue, Resi? Can you explain it now? >> Wait, so I
deleted my DMs the stream after you said anybody who tells you
anything in private, and you said this to Aeko. You said anybody
who tells me anything in private, I will immediately publish
whatever it is if I feel like >> If it's interesting. Yeah.
No, I will. That's true. >> It's interesting. And >> what's
the issue with IEO? >> And you've literally you What's
the issue with that, Perry? You say that you're going to publish
anything I tell you in private, >> right? But this doesn't
have to do with the EIO stuff that caused you to hate me. That's
what I want to focus on. Just you whining about me. >> Perry.
Perry, I'm telling you what it's actually about and you're trying
to >> because I said the DMing. Is that why you burned
the bridge? Really? Yeah. If you're not, if you're going to speak
what he's saying, I
you're Catholic and you are that's why you keep calling Perry
calling a priest because looks like the guy that you Okay, so
real quick when you say you are going you call my grandmother
a dementia patient, you can burn alive, freak. All >> listen.
I listen your grandmother is a dementia patient. You didn't bring
trust. You are a prophetic. What's your point? Your point is
that you're not
by a guy that looks like that's why you've been calling. You
were by a guy that looks like
>> you are
guy that looks like >> Are you going to make your points
about
you by dickers?
>> I'm actually making the argument. I'm actually making
the argument. Harry. Wait, guys. I need to say >> Harry
actually
me. This guy just meid.
>> If we're going to go this conversation,
I'm going to moderate the conversation, then pick a side and
go. You're obviously on the
Let me reach out to Aiden who's going to back me up. I'm reach
out to this guy. The same guy reached out to me.
and resiad and resi everybody. So I happen to agree actually
resi a little bit more with your performance here but now because
you said that I'm a little offended. Second of all, >> okay,
and get over.
>> Really? You want to say that to me with your grandmother?
>> Just ignore his gap. >> My grandmother
people that would have tied you to a steak. I don't know what
>> grandmother can't pull the trigger. Her fingers are
too weak from gooning to watch you have sex. >> Perry.
Perry, you make conversations unlistable because you're like
going a thousand miles an hour. >> Why is it always me,
man? This resi guy sp the whole time. >> Why is it always
me, man? Why don't my responsibility?
What the hell?
>> Small island. Small beans. Small island.
>> You're not yelling at Timmy. Then what the hell?
>> Sping out because he's given up on the prospect of having
an actual >> I gave up on the prospect of having a conversation
before the season. >> Oh, yeah. You're sping out.
>> Well, you make it par like going 1,000 miles hour like
a tornado like waiting waiting to interrupt or like the second
they pop. It's because he's BPD splitting cuz he was by a priest
that looked like >> No, it's probably just >> Well,
Aiden, can you like say the point about the IEO stuff, I guess?
And >> I don't have >> Yeah. So, the point I had
about the IEO stuff was very specifically when you said you're
going to release any DM if you find it necessary. Yeah. I'm going
to delete my DM. >> I'm going to delete my DMs with you
and I'm not going to interact with you. Is that that seems like
a reasonable thing to do. You just never brought this up and
you just all the other points you were making those were like
that's why you wanted to bring if I bring this up >> You
still brought stuff up but you just brought Wait
about you having a harassment community
>> I didn't bring up this >> has directly to do with
you being embarrassed. Yes. >> Wait, hold up. Hold up.
Wait. But you cut off IO at the same time, right? >> Uh
with the leaking stuff. Uh
it was soft and then it got harder recently. Yeah. He kept talking
like it was basically over at the same time. It seemed like Perry
and Ieko were dumb because of that conversation. It seemed like
it was kind of tied together. >> Um I was kind of willing
to see out Iiko cuz I've known IO for a while, but then recently
I was just like, yeah, I can't really get over the incipid uh
bug that's in the back of my head to uh kind of rectify the situation.
I was more willing to do it cuz I've known Nico for years. I
don't I've known Perry for what, four or five months or something
like that.
are living in harmony.
>> Okay. Well, why were you cutting Io off? Is that
>> Um I mean at the end of it it's Yeah, it's the leaking
stuff. I just kind of like just that was like the main
>> Uh she was not leaking the stuff with me. not even actually
specifically stuff with uh it was just like the kind of continued
pattern that she displayed
during the smug whiz stuff and like kind of uh trying to follow
along with it. It
like there was no real attempt there and then just realized yeah
there's a pretty high chance that
>> doesn't make sense. The smoke stuff was after your stuff,
wasn't it? >> I know. But it provided a pattern for me
to realize that there is something that I believe has changed
about Ieko. Right. >> Wait says the reason why she leaks
this kind of stuff is because she has OCD around people.
>> Is that
>> So um
after you talked to you DM me all of these emotional DMs about
how you care about me, how you were going to right now. Right
now, >> let me talk. Let me [__] talk. Okay,
let me let me talk. So, you sent me all of these emotional DMs.
You were like I said that you were going to properly cover my
Chud coverage cuz you you said publicly on stream appropo of
nothing that my coverage of uh of Chud's trans tent was had an
air of transphobia. So, I see that and I'm like, what the what
the is going on? So, I get angry. I'm live. I talk to Perry.
You join, right? After after we fight, you talk to Then you tell
me that you care about me. You want to go to the beach. You care
about me as your friend. So, you're going to you're going to
properly go over my Chud transent uh coverage like you should
have from the beginning, right? 3 weeks later, nothing nothing
you nothing happens. And then suddenly you just don't want to
you just don't want to be friends anymore.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Can I Can >> No,
I don't need I don't need you to
>> So So yes, I uh I am a emotional guy. Uh Perry has been
or not Perry. Uh Queman has noted this for years by saying that
I have a um what is it? A child audience. Uh Quimman, I think
that's what you said that like I'm an emotional
>> I feel like yeah, that's pretty much where it's been.
Um, yeah, I'm a pretty >> So, you just had an emotional
meltdown at the time and >> Yeah, because I did value our
>> So, what what did I do exactly? What
>> So, when you go ahead and just start leaking a lot of
stuff on the >> What did I leak?
>> Uh, it was with a smuggly >> smug lies to me.
And what does that have to do with our friendship? What does
that have to do with >> Wait, wait, wait. No. Smug lied
to me, so I leaked his DMs. That's my policy. You've always known
this. If you lie to me, I will leak >> I will leak whatever
whenever you saw what happened with Becket.
>> So what what's different now? Exactly. And why you care
about Smug Bug so much? >> Well, no. I can't Whiz hates
you. What is your issue? >> I know. He called me a doctor
to you and you didn't tell me about that. That was really cool.
Um >> No, you didn't. No, you said that he did on your
one stream. You said that there's somebody boxing or harassing
or something like that and then you said that Oh, yeah. Right.
>> No. What are you talking about? That never happened.
What the are you talking >> I literally recall exactly.
>> No, that was about Smug. That was about he Whiz made
that Smug was was potentially going to do him. >> No, no.
Remember that whiz said you in the in the whiz things, you know,
he deleted something.
>> Oh, that was uh that was um I corrected that because
it was in Perry's chat that Whiz said something about >> No,
no, no. That's what it was. I clarified I know. I clarified this
>> You were reviewing your your Discord DMs with Whiz.
>> Yes. And then Whiz DM'd me and he sent me a clip of
Perry's stream that I for completely forgot that I DM'd Whiz
because of him saying that Smug was going to dox him in Perry's
chat and I was just checking. I was just checking in. It had
nothing to do with you. >> Yeah, I recall you specifically
saying that it was about me because Smug and Whiz had >> nothing
to do with you. >> Wait, wait, no. Smug and Whiz have both
kind of elicited those exact things on stream as well.
>> Yes, they did during
they they went ahead and said that me and Queman are part of
a doxing community. That was during >> That was during
the JREG thing. The JREG uh it was Jreg
that >> on stream. >> You sent it to me but deleted
it. >> The clip of >> Yeah, I did. I know. So anyways,
um
>> uh no, I I'm not sign. You can go. >> What? What
is he talking about?
>> There's a Jreg um smug collab where apparently the smug
said something about doxing, but I don't think it that's what
it said, but I couldn't. You know, Ray sent me a clip and he
deleted it cuz he's mad at me. So that's what he's referring
to, I'm not sure if you saw the Jreg smug collab.
>> No, I didn't. So this had nothing to do with me. Can
we just confirm this? Can we confirm that I never said anything
to do with you and doxing whatsoever?
>> Okay, that's >> Yes, let's acknowledge that. That
was about Whiz and Smug.
>> Yes. So, I clarified this on my stream. So, if you want
to go back just to check. I'm not lying.
>> I I'm not going to go back and check. Why the [__]
>> Okay. So, give me a real reason why you ended our friendship.
>> That's the real reason. I guess I was wrong and I've
decided to continue not doing the friendship thing cuz I just
don't trust you. Sorry.
>> Okay. Well, this doesn't Okay. Well, this all seems
very strange to me now because you're saying that Perry has a
harassment community that he's associated with. >> I think
the real complaint is changing to, well, you leaked stuff. But
then the leak cut off happens to coincide with also the cut off
from Ieko, which >> I
debate. Now the reasoning Now the reasoning is changing to a
doxing thing
>> he said my community was harassing him
>> He said my community was harassing him too. Meanwhile,
it was his own chatters that were our mutual community that were
>> I should respond. >> Okay. Sure. Sorry. Sorry.
Go ahead. >> Yeah. So once again, yeah, you can separate
out the Perry and the Ieko things. Okay.
I'm I >> around the same time and see you have reasons
that >> change weeks between right Iiko because I told
you that no longer >> No, I told you I was no longer interested
in being friends with you three weeks after I stopped talking
to >> Yeah, because I DM'd you and I said you know that
that they're just baiting us, right? Because Smug were DMing
us. Yes. And you Yeah. At some point I gave you space during
that three weeks. I thought you were going to talk to me later.
All of your excuses have been [__] I didn't do anything.
So, if you don't trust me, that's completely fine. I haven't
changed. You >> want me to That's totally fine. >> That's
fine. Yeah. I just don't trust >> Yeah, I accept that.
You just could have You could have told me that you don't want
to be friends with me instead of leaving me hanging for 3 weeks.
Me defending you. >> Yeah, I me defending you to everyone.
>> Well, I you didn't really defend me. You >> I
did. What do you want from me? >> I did. to everyone.
>> I don't know who. Yes. I I don't know who's get putting
this in your head. I don't know if what you've been looking >> You
can just say duck. You can just say you can just be >> Yes,
you're [__] There we go.
I know that it's it's darkness. I don't think we should jump
to any conclusions, but it seems to all be around this trans
conversation. Really? I remember I remember very clearly. Well,
not very clearly, but I remember the trans >> The one I
ruined by bring CPCA in that one. If I didn't do that, you should
be friends. I believe at this point it's gone beyond the trans
conversation. So that's like a >> Yeah, because you're
sping out >> seems to actually
seem to actually be rooted in that and then the the other reasons
seem to
>> develop after that possibly. >> It's post talk.
Yeah. >> Okay. But
I lost I >> don't even know what the going on here. >> Yeah,
I'm an emotional guy kind of late. >> I actually I've been
sitting here. I'm not like walked away. I just have nothing to
enter instead of watch any of this content. >> Any actual
I barely know who Duck Bringer is and I was too much for you
and ever since at this point this is just like a
free broadcast.
>> You're just not going to engage with the fact that it's
true what I'm saying which is that you for months have been lying
about both of us cuz you've seemingly went badly in a debate.
>> No, it's been four weeks, right? >> Four weeks.
Months. My bad, man. My bad. A month crash out. >> I also
specifically haven't said anything about Ieko on my stream
Even after you said that, I told everyone to leave you alone,
that everything is is like we're not talking about it. I haven't
been talking about it. I think that this is all very convenient.
And of course, I don't want to be friends with someone who doesn't
want to be friends with me. If I had known you had any of these
feelings about me, I would not be friends a long time ago. >> We
can rebuild this bridge. >> Hold up. No, no, no, no. Stop
saying hurtful things to each other. What are you doing >> now?
Shut up. Can you guys just
>> needs a segment for tomorrow? JT, shut the up.
>> God, I want people. Why can't we just be
>> Don't you guys Don't you guys remember? Don't you guys
remember Tom? >> Don't you guys?
>> Didn't Tom bring us all together?
>> We just need We need Tom his career up one more time.
>> Useless interruption.
>> How about this? Here's a question that I wanted to know.
Uh why why does why does send all of these weird DMs to Perry
when you guys like >> Hey, if if I may. >> Yeah,
but she like spurs out about the deletes and says, "Yeah, you
paid attention. You won." >> Excuse me. >> It's very
freakish. >> Isn't that because Perry reminds her of like
her ex who used to be abusive?
>> Possibly. So remember that she said, >> "I've
never broken someone made them." >> Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know. >> Doesn't matter what she said. No, no, no. This
is about me. [__] you. Burn alive. Burn alive. So,
when it comes to the day What day was the
What was the day that Duck sent the haha
>> I don't know. Like Monday. >> No, no, it wasn't
Monday. It wasn't a >> It was uh Well, I remember the day
she deleted it. What do you want from me? What was >> it?
Well, no, because you you shopped these around and sent them
to people. You should know that, right? >> I shopped the
fact that she I deleted the message. I can't shop around and
deleted the message. You just lied when she sent that when your
top mod and top donator Paragon was outed as a freak. >> No,
that was the
wrong You're just lying again. The time here is all wrong. You
just make it up to us.
You're a loser.
>> Multiple stuff was when I went from street to make major
windy. And there are multiple ones like Ako was saying. >> Okay.
But the specific ones that you laundered which were the ones
the launder I just mention that she was DMing me I'm asking no
I'm actually asking Iiko were the ones that you laundered were
the ones right >> those are the ones you
>> remember sending them to my show cuz those were the
ones that were >> where are you getting this like information
from >> probably the only party involved
>> is wrong
>> everything you think you know is wrong. So I I don't
I don't know exactly. So, I'm just saying maybe wh why is she
DMing
Harry so much? Like still >> it insp
my stream >> and and commenting on my VOD my
>> Well, no, wait. I did you not say the same thing about
sport? You're complaining about my harassment community or harassment
community. But then I >> complaining about your harassment
Yes, I harassed. >> She's a little strange. She's a little
strange. I don't know about
no issue with Yeah, I'm pretty strange. I get it. Yeah,
>> Well, you're a straight freak and you're like going
after other people and crying about what we do when what you
do and justify is way worse. And >> you're clearly have
an emotional breakdown. I want to pretend there's a justification.
And whenever I say >> Harry, Harry, I want to focus in
on that stuff. What What's Reser done to you? >> What's
Res done to me? Well, you just being a gay loser and lying about
me. It's annoying. Why? Because >> Yeah. Like lying about
your affiliated community that you're affiliated with. That's
what I've said. I've said nothing in public about Iiko about
any of this until now. >> Well, you've been talking about
Eeko on your stream, so that's not true. And you talk about all
the time whenever I find clips about me.
>> Does that really count as public? >> Well, if
he counts a spicy convo as public. Well, anyway, it's very clear
whenever he brings me up, he brings
and I where I literally said to you in private the issues I had
with you. >> I don't remember this happening, man. I lost
you ever being there, man. >> Point. It helps your point.
All right. You're on. >> That doesn't really help my point.
It just means you have to reiterate it really, but it doesn't
help my point. >> Over and over again because you don't
>> Yeah. And I very disagree with it that you're bad. Yeah.
I don't think your point's very good. The point is what? That
I have bad realistic standards cuz I brought a mentally ill man
on my stream and disagreed with him and told him to get therapy.
That doesn't make any [__] sense. That's bad. >> It's
clearly not It's literally not at all what I said, but you know,
make up your own narrative. That's fine. I >> Yeah, you're
talking about the text stuff and you're talking about DM
in this conversation to you and you literally didn't even listen
to that to begin with. So
>> maybe Yeah. Why am I Why? >> Just don't repeat
the point. Okay, just say that you already made the point. Don't
repeat. No repeats.
>> Work community is filled with lollycon freaks. I'm going
to do that. >> Yeah. Focus on the one that makes you
>> I'm going to do that forever. You're going to call me.
>> This isn't that deep.
>> Buddy, I saw Auggie said he was going to stream, but
I haven't seen the stream. >> What's your point, Ry? Is
that you're like spuring out and willing to lie and Oh, that's
it. You just got to deal with it, Perry. I know. I mean, I guess.
>> Yeah. You do actually cuz that's all that's an issue.
The problem is he's lying. You're okay with lying and
>> Harry. Okay. He's willing to lie. What is he lying about?
>> Well, he's lying about the details of who my community
is, so to speak, and also my junic standards and also I don't
know everything to do with Iiko. Just a lot of this conversation.
Yeah. >> Well, I mean I mean again, the IO stuff is ancillary
to you. Yeah, I won't lie. >> Well, okay. So, but it just
shows you're a liar. My poor >> He said I was obsessed
with Tyler.
>> Yeah, he did say that. >> Yeah, you are. I am.
How am I more obsessed than anyone else that milks >> Okay,
but like here's the thing. Is that Am I lying if I say you're
obsessed with >> You're the one that had a million alerts
of her barking like a dog. >> I have a million alerts of
her own, but she doesn't attack you anymore. >> Say we're
both obsessed. What? >> We're both obsessed.
>> But you're the one
and then say we're both obsessed. What are you talking about?
>> You are bad at this. Come on. >> It's not funny.
>> [__] you. I love >> you're bad at
bullshitting. >> Resi be like, I made a bad argument and
that's okay. Actually, that just is what it is. That's what you've
been doing this whole time, Resi. Just like admit that you did
have a good point and don't like try gut out of the fact that
you're just like sping out emotionally with >> Stick with
not trusting me for for vibes. I just want to state I didn't
do anything wrong here. And uh I think I have a healthy obsession
with Kyla because she is amazing memes. Okay. And you used to
know that it's >> I've been
like ready to go after this. That's like the next thing I'm doing
on stream. So I don't know what to tell you. I'm >> I don't
even care about this. I care
>> You're just throwing shots at me for no
>> When I was
the IO conversation with Smug Bug, JTO said that he didn't think
that I had a good justification to leak and that she went back
on it. M I think Ieko wanted to leak and the reason she leaked
was not actually the reason that uh ended up being like true.
>> Like she leaked because she thought I watched it was
>> I watched your coverage. No, that was my intention.
Like I I had a singular point, a singular focus. And so I let
him take me around a little bit. But that singular focus of him
saying that Becket sent it to him. uh when Becca did not when
I saw that >> wasn't sorry that wasn't what you brought
up and told him that wasn't the the pretext for you leaking what
you told him. So if you just didn't state that correctly it's
fine >> at at the time in that one
short conversation that was the we had already established this
>> and that's what I kept going back to. So that's why
that line cuz Becket uh hearing that that smug said that Becket
sent it to him. Becket found that out or Becket heard that. Um
I went and talked to Becket. He said that it was a lie. So that's
why that was >> and that's why that's why Becket was super
chill with Whiz the next day when he talked with him, right?
>> What? Wait, why are you asking me about this? What?
What? Okay. What? You're not paying attention.
>> No, of course. [__] seems like screaming
at each other like I tuned this conversation out like 10 minutes.
talking about the smug why I leaked the smug DMs because he said
that you sent him the Pixie Kyla
DMs and uh and you did not you didn't have them at the time that
he had them. You didn't have them till later. So since that wasn't
the since that was a lie, I decided to leak and see what he had
to say for himself. That is my policy. If you lie to me, I will
leak it whenever. >> Yeah. I I I don't know what the point
is about Wiz. Yeah, I spoke to I spoke to Whiz. Um,
Whiz probably lied to me, but it's also like whatever with the
convers part of that is conversations that wasn't streamed. So,
it's like
>> So, yet another hollow excuse for something that I don't
>> No, I mean for but but like Whiz and Smug's position
is that they they they just want to lie and troll. That's their
actual position. Both of them like
>> So, it's kind of I don't know why we've got I don't
know why we've got here from the fact >> well it's because
Resi wants to find some excuse out of the millu of things that
occur to explain why he had a spur out about Eko and me that's
the reason
>> But you can go back to beds now.
>> Yeah. I mean I I I mean my genuine question is like
so this argument between you and I seem to have occurred over
the Chad stuff. It seems like >> Chud doesn't give a [__]
>> Um
100%. >> I mean, you've disagreed with Iiko before. I don't
know why this became as big as it did >> and you guys have
been friends for ages, which seems like a dumb bridge to burn.
That was just my opinion. You can do what you want. Obviously,
I'm not to police your friendships, but that's just how I think
people are going to see it,
>> Is that is that an issue like to me or >> Well,
he's going to make it's an issue cuz he's going to vake post
about on his stream for months after months while saying he doesn't
care if that counts. >> It's been It's been four weeks,
isn't it? It's been a month since, you know, been whining about
it >> after months >> in the background the whole
>> Let him answer Becket's question.
>> I actually don't know what specifically it was. It's
like Becket, I'm sorry. Can you rephrase it one more time? >> Is
it okay? So, what what's the actual issue here? Like, you've
fallen out with Iiko. People are like, "That's a weird That's
weird that you've fallen out with her. It seems like a weird
thing for you guys to fall out over in the first
>> Um, yeah. I mean, that seems reasonable. I I mean I
don't know why >> question do I care?
>> Yeah, I still don't understand why anyone sort of like
Harry is a troll. Harry is an obvious troll. >> Yeah, just
don't engage with me, man. Just lie about me whenever you want
and uh meme out of it when confronted. That's really cool. >> Hold
on. Hold on. Let me let me let me finish the Harry's thing is
he wants to get a reaction out of you. >> Yes, correct.
>> But I don't lie about people like Resi does. Man, what
the hell? >> Well, I mean you do, but it's okay. >> Oh,
you do. You do. Are you hitting that you lie then? >> Hold
on. >> Oh my god.
>> Echo, shut the [__] up. >> No, I think
um he's going to sweep away from this. Resi does lie about people.
But it's okay when he does it. But Perry does it. He's evil.
A bad fate and we can do anything to him. >> Okay. I was
just going to say, sorry, you said some unhinged things about
>> Name one. Name one thing. Name one >> You called
>> I didn't call I called him a machine and I wrapped about
it. Yeah. a machine for alter boys, which is the same as calling
someone a
right here.
I need to say I was never Catholic.
>> Yeah, you're saying you were
>> I want to be I don't believe you because >> what
the is a presterarian?
>> No,
the reality is a looks just like >> You mean Presbyterian?
You
>> are I will keep him speaking.
>> Wait. Well, >> at least you're not right.
>> I couldn't hear about
>> I couldn't hear the accusation from over the screaming.
What's What's being >> Oh, I said at least at least you're
not a pescatarian.
>> Well, listen. Basically, Resi wants to conflate me making
jokes about how um this is the machine that prowls the streets
of Birmingham to find little boys to meet. Okay. He wants to
conflate that between him just lying about my community and the
way I engage with
you know live you weirdo.
>> Saying Bernim is funny. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. >> Oh,
wait. No, Perry. You're flawed because I'm not lying about your
>> You are. You are. You lie about mine.
Several members of your community were engaged in a lollycon
server with >> Yeah, but they're not members of my community.
They're members of the space. And you try to conflate that with
me having an issue when you say that they're harassing. >> Well,
yeah, I am saying that because I'm not saying you're >> I'm
just saying it's very curious that you're surrounded by >> Yeah.
You just try and deeply push these
when they're just a common, etc. Is this the Is this the weird
accusation came out that the dude the dog with the melon on its
head or something was like
3 days after after about 3 days after Perry and his chosen one
Spinal BJ and a bunch of people danced on Melon Dog's grave and
they basically got revealed for doing something significantly
worse. >> Oh, what spinal BJ? Was it a holy shocking shocking
I don't know. Well, the thing is, Becca, the thing is he's saying
that I knew about this the whole time when I knew about the server.
I was in it.
>> Harry, come on. Defend Spinal BJ. You said that MK was
more likely to be a than Spinal BJ. And he was running a server
where children were in the same voice call. >> That's true.
Still stand by that. M is way more of a danger. I didn't say
more like I said more likely to be a danger to kids. To be clear,
she's more likely to be a danger. >> What kind of danger?
Was she going to drive drunk? Uh well maybe
ignore that fact. Ignore that fact.
>> Spanish people, you know, etc., etc. But the idea that
like what? So I like Spinal does a weird thing even though I
criticize Spinal before and that means that my community is filled
with people and I knew about the weird server that A had. There's
just such a extension that
Spinal had to be fair. He was a head mod >> Oh, I don't
know. I didn't look into the >> It wasn't
even content about it. >> Let's be Let's be clear. It was
not a Okay, it was >> I'm being
>> Let's be real. Stop sweeping. >> I had this I
had this argument with Queenman. Okay. I think that the server
was reckless in the sense that it had a minor attracted per somebody
who listed themselves as a minor attracted
>> in a in a server with minors. I think >> okay.
If you have a server where people are self-identifying
as minor attractive
>> why can't you? >> Wait, Spinal admitted to several.
>> I I only saw one. There's only one that I know of.
>> Maybe they Yeah, Spinal on admitted to several. Like
this is just >> I'm not defending I'm not defending the
server, by the way. I had Quean went at me for going too hard
on the server owner, so you know.
>> Okay. Well, yeah, because You got to stop instead. >> Queen
doesn't view Lollcon as like
and he's made his arguments as to why. >> No, it would
be it would be if it was like an actual like lolly server where
they had miners in there. But my understanding is it was a general
>> That started between a few friends that were around
like 18 to 21
or something. Started with a few friends like that. and they
had friends that were under 18
already pre-existing friendships with these people and they invited
those and the server just gradually expanded over time. Eventually
there's a couple of maps in there and they have a private section
where they talk about and games together but the miners aren't
in the private section and obviously once it's raised all the
miners get banned. >> Yeah. So the problem
no
excuse me
hold on please shut up.
>> Shut up resi or I'll mute you. What do you mean there
was a server with [__] maps in it and it was like
well the miners were b like is that not a pedo server then by
definition? Is that not like exactly? No, there's a difference
between being there being a server that's about being able or
is about
versus there is a server that has both and miners in it. That's
probably like yo a significant percent
and this is a small contribution. >> You just described
somebody
what is going on. No, there is one
problem with what Queen is saying is that there was not moderation
for my thanks for 10, buddy. All this blew up. That was revealed
during DJ call that >> Yes. And the only skating when I
spoke to him about it. >> Yeah, exactly. Like they literally
were trying to offiscate and act like, you know, oh, we weren't
doing these things. >> Okay. Why? How do we know that?
Wait, so what we saying? Spinal said they only moderated that
day. >> Well, no, it wasn't Spinal. was a a 14A or whatever
the his name is. >> Yes. But >> he said they only
banned them that day. He said they only banned them that day.
>> He said that he only banned them but they were trying
to intimate that the minors were not able to access the voice
calls and then they banned them that day because there was no
such
>> No, I think I I know what happened better than than
you do or something because my understanding is basically that
there were two separate channels or two separate sets of channels.
They had a channel that got added at some point that um miners
couldn't access, but they could always access the the voice uh
call in the in the main section. That was my understanding. >> Yeah,
but by >> Yeah, go ahead. Sorry. >> By being able
to access the main section, you've created >> No, they
can't. I don't think they can >> No, sorry. No, no, sorry.
Sorry, not the I mean the public VC. My bad. By being able to
access the public VC, you've put them in a scenario now where
where
minor attracted persons are still >> I agree with this.
Yes. Yes. The reckless thing to do, but the idea that it's a
server, you're like saying that you're like trying to say that
it's a server set up to groom kids. That is what you're saying
there. That's obviously not the case. It's a bunch of 20-year-olds
that had friends that were as young as like 17.
Like I I don't >> So it's not it's not the purpose of the
server. It's just incidental. It created a reckless. We It didn't
even happen. It didn't even happen. We haven't shown >> It's
just kind of an It's an accident. >> I'm sorry. Okay. Just
so we're This is a game then like so many Discord servers are
servers. So
>> he's talking about like selfidentified
>> I say one trans Twitch streamer that identified that
at some point changed their flag on their profile picture. allegedly
changed uh their flag on their profile picture from trans to
map that the like colored flag on their profile picture and and
that happened at some point apparently and that person is identified
as a map.
>> I believe that Spinal actually said that there were
several people in the server who selfidentified. >> Got
it wrong. He didn't know what he was talking about. There have
been only there's only been one I could find.
>> But they did have a child role, right? They had a minor
role. >> It was it was shown it was shown separately to
the to the other roles in the in the sidebar, right? >> Yeah.
And I argue that creates a really reckless situation. >> No,
that's fine. I'm not accusing you of being a pedophile, Aiden,
to be clear. You looked like too much of a child to be a pedophile,
but just pointed that >> No, I'm not. No, I wasn't in the
server. I wasn't in the server. I'm not saying you're accusing
me of anything. I'm saying I I >> He was in the server.
>> I interrogated the owner as a result of hearing about
this. Literally just some
random and spinal BJ I think is >> I think Perry as well
>> I was not in the server in the server was never in the
server >> I didn't know existed but resi wants to like
appeal me using it >> yeah I just think it's known existed
weird there is no evidence there is no evidence you were in the
server there was no evidence >> or knew about it
and when did he know about it like and how would he know >> I
knew about it when the file stream. I didn't Yeah, he's using
it to attack me. I have a harass with community. It's so gay.
It's so gay and pathetic. >> True. Resi defending parry
bridge bridge mended. I awesome. >> I mean, no, I'm going
to actually block him after this. So, like, you're good. >> I
don't message you. Why would you I guess I messaged you. >> No,
you you did message me. You did message me. You called me. >> I
said call in to confront me. You
No, it wasn't call in to confront me. You called me and then
you said I said call me. Why would I do that? Now, obviously
you can find his I can't find uh your DMs where you're saying
it's all content, dude. I don't even care about the ICO stuff.
And then you talking about it. >> You can't do that because
I deleted them, right? >> Yeah, that's what I'm getting
at. And then I said, "You're a loser." And I stand by that. >> Was
it just that you're I think it could be just your >> Oh,
I deleted DMs. Yeah, that's where you're going to get. Very,
very telling mind. Very telling where your mind goes. But no,
I did not spend all day being a >> in a pet. You and your
fat girl. >> Oh, yeah. No, you didn't say you're a you
are a loser. Exclamation point. That is what you said after I
didn't answer your call at 8:30 and 8 8:41 in the
>> 8:44 in the morning. Sorry.
>> And you are. And I think we can all >> That was
not me. I disavow. I completely disavow. That was not me. >> You
have a community. >> Okay. So Perry and Queman are just
going to keep like >> there's some question of whether
Perry
>> You're just You're actively saying you're just lying.
>> Just going to keep saying [__]
Cleman is I have no reason to believe is an app any more than
like any other person I engage with online. >> I mean again
>> just in case. Okay. Just in case. Get that get that
hedge in there. >> I talk about politics all day. I just
happen to like have a spur out every single stream about you
and I go. Okay. >> I don't talk about politics every day.
I >> That's what you're saying. I'm going to talk about
serious stuff. I don't care about this. Um >> No, I I'm
not saying that
anyway. I just don't seek out conversations. Like I I don't know
what to tell you. No, you just like um they post about in every
single stream while saying that you're above it all. That's what
you do. >> Can I ask something? You guys alluded to a trans
phobia conversation. Was this >> It's uh I can send it
to you.
>> Was the premise of this Resi accusing Cha of being transphobic.
and I said that Aiko's lane of attack I felt had a vibe of transphobia
at his
said was in the same way. >> I need to speak for this.
Okay, I I need to sweep for this. Okay, what Res was saying is
that it was transphobic or had the flavor of transphobia
in the same way that Ethan Klein has the flavor of Islamophobia.
Bearing in mind that Res doesn't think that Res doesn't think
that Ethan Klein actually is
pointed out to him the fact that the allegations of Islamophobia
are there and obviously with the Ramadan stuff, right, which
would turned out to be but whatever. And Resir said yes, he was
wrong and that was a bad way to proven that sweep over. >> Yeah,
I I'm just going to be clear. I don't think that Ethan is trans.
I don't even necessarily fully think I think again he has the
flavor of it but I think he uses a lot of
>> I know I'm but now talk about Iiko just
>> well yeah my my argument is is that the argument that
Io was using against Chud which was basically you know what I
constitute to be a shame argument
right was shaming him for his attraction to trans individuals
>> nope not at all
comparable situation that is what I was That answer you were
saying and you were wrong about the >> Guys, shut up. That
ico answer. >> I was uh I was shaming and mocking Chud
for his trans tent, his coverage he that he does, which is absolutely
influenced by his shame in getting caught
a trans person. my opinion accurate.
>> I'm mocking him, not for being attracted to trans people,
but for coping, for saying that he was groomed essentially, not
denying it. I asked him, "Do you believe that you were groomed
by trans people into being attracted to one?" And he said, "Nice
try. I don't talk about my personal blah blah blah." And not
even a little bit of a no. Okay. He was responding to the previous
question too. I thought that's important. He did respond to like
the previous question and then that one he he wouldn't respond
>> Yes, he responded to the previous one which I asked
him. Do you believe that or do you think that maybe your uh evolving
takes on trans people have anything to do with being caught a
trans person? And then he went off for about 10 minutes going
in depth about his takes. And then I asked him about being groomed.
That's when he didn't want to talk about it. So everything that
I'm >> did he respond? Did he respond to clarify? Was that
first question he responded to from you?
>> Okay. And then he didn't respond to I >> the second
one he said nice try I go. >> Yeah. I think Chud has inated
similar similar sort of sentiments before that he feels like
he was he was tricked into liking trans people.
>> Okay. Am I crazy or is there something about it being
co that like he was stuck inside during co
>> having you freak go investigate Chud on my stream. I'm
actually not doing that. >> I don't think investigations.
I think people have investigated and come to
>> Can we agree though? >> Why can't we on your stream
derail? Let's not derail with this matter over. Let go finish,
please. >> Thank you. I just want Can we all agree? I don't
think that that mocking Chud for his coping about being groomed
instead of just not even talking about it, living his life. Like,
I'm not shaming him for being attracted to >> maybe if
it's >> he doesn't have to say anything. It's just he's
relentlessly he's on this campaign of cope and making fun of
the cope not being attracted to a trans person. Does anyone disagree?
>> what prison gay? But the prison was his
>> I don't even think you're prison. I think that I think
that he's >> talk about what I'm talking about. What I'm
talking >> phobic in the same way Ethan islamophobic or
whatever it >> Yes. comparing me to Ethan Klein and Islamophobia
is insane.
But so what I'm saying, No, I don't care. I don't care. I don't
care. Answer what I was asking.
It was very clear when you said this. I think what I just said,
what my overall point is, what I'm doing, which is mocking his
cope about about his engagement with uh trans people, making
fun of his cope, not about his uh attraction to them.
Do you think that's
>> How is it a cope if it's about his
>> No, he's he's mocking he's mocking them. He's saying
that he called contra points a wolf in sheep's clothing. He goes
on about the AGP, how they how they are brainwashing like him
saying that as a man in his mid30s,
you know, not isolated just online
talking having being friends with trans people is being groomed
by the left into being attracted to trans people. I think that's
insane. I'm making fun of that. So is that transphobic? >> What
the are you saying? Is Chud transphobic or the way >> am
I transphobic? You said I was I said a flavor of transphobia.
>> I have very clearly said over and over again. I find
the argument to have the heirs of transphobia. I >> again
what I just said you think what I just said this for yourself.
>> No I'm not. That's exactly was listening. And you sound
like you are. No, wait, wait. You are refraraming my statements
about Ethan Klein's Islamophobia
to go ahead and be a full encompassment of himself when I'm specifically
saying he has actions that carry the heirs of that and that is
the comparison that I made. >> I think he's Islamophobia.
But do
>> Do I think Do I actions have the heirs of Islamophob
transphobia? Do they? Yes or no?
>> Yeah, they did.
Yes, everyone else sees it as being no. That's the issue. >> The
way Okay. Well, guess what? I didn't. And I argued with I about
it for 2 hours and then at the end of it, we agreed to disagree.
The next day on stream, a lot of my chatters asked, "Why are
you letting Io walk over you with all this?" And I'm just like,
"Because she wants to do what she wants to do."
>> she saw the two-minute clips where I'm like, "Yeah,
everybody's transphobic like Queen and Silo and all that." Because
we influence the language of gawkchasing. When we say gawkchaser
so it's never about so if it was 1910 and I called somebody a
body a body part that is below the waist the knee and then I
asked if it growed right would that be make me a racist from
1910?
>> I don't know what the [__] you're talking
about.
I don't know what you're talking about. I don't care. >> I
know. He say he's actually doing >> Say the word. >> I
still presently think it's
>> I'm on kick. Go. >> I didn't even hear what you
said. >> Yeah. Go ahead. >> No. Sorry. >> I'm
off I'm off Twitch. >> You just said that. Go ahead. >> I
I forgot that Resi was on Sorry, Becky was on YouTube. >> I
I literally as you said that I ended the Twitch stream. No, no.
As you said that, I ended the Twitch stream. Everything's fine.
No big deal. >> That's fine. >> Wow. So cool. Okay.
Can you answer? >> Can you answer? Do you think what I
>> No. So you still think what I was doing is transphobic.
>> I still think the argument you're making as the heirs
of transphobia. >> Okay. That's your problem. No one else
agrees with you. So that's fine with me. >> Fine. I go.
>> It's your problem. And you've hated Eeko ever since.
And you
relationship. >> It seems like confronted about it on stream
and embarrassed. Everything that you say there is an absolute
counter to it. So you just have just just be like, "Oh, I don't
like you." And that's fine. You don't have to say I'm doing anything
wrong cuz I'm not I'm not doing >> Okay. Yes. That is why
you keep saying she does stuff wrong on your stream posting about
her. >> We could [__] Okay. You could have
just told me you didn't want to be friends. Okay. You left me
hanging for
>> You don't treat me with respect as a
>> I absolutely don't. And I should have told you earlier.
I can absolutely admit that I probably should have told you earlier,
but I had like some personal like, you know, issues that I was
like thinking about with it. And then at one point I'm just like,
yeah, I don't want to continue this >> thing. Specifically
after you said that Smug and Perry were trying to separate >> and
they were What are you talking about? Well, no. That's like what
>> they were coming. They were DMing me about you. Yeah.
Why would that m Why would that even matter if I was saying
>> You don't like either of them, right? >> Yeah.
And I had a fundamental issue with you. That's why I was like,
"Hey, I don't want you to keep defending me when I don't think
I'm going to defend you one thing." >> Okay. Which is pathetic.
>> Clear. Okay. absolutely pathetic that I had to reach
out to you.
>> that's fine. If I had known you were even on the fence
about being friends with me during this time, I would have ended
that right away. You think I need you think I don't have other
friends that I would need to to beg you to be my friend cuz you're
loser. Okay, you don't even have good
Excuse me. No, I Excuse me. Was it not very early on? But I said
I literally said to you I >> said what? What? >> I
literally said to you when this started that I wasn't necessarily
sure we were going to be able to work this out. Did >> I
not say that? >> You said that and then you DM'd me later
after talking to and you were like, "I love you. I want to go
to the beach. I'm going to do this because I care about you and
you're my friend and I hate that you're upset." Nothing after
that. >> Yes, I did all those things. I've >> That's
the last that I heard of it. I was waiting. I was patient. You
were like, "I don't deserve your kindness." >> You were
like grateful that I was giving you the >> How many times
in a row did you say I love you? It's key to hit that multiple.
>> Uh I think
I think it I think it was like 19 or something like that. So
yeah, I'm like
coming through. >> Yeah, dude. I honestly I I couldn't
figure it out. Yeah. >> Did you ever boil down to resi
is dating Yoka Ono? Yes. Yeah. >> Oh, yeah. Partially.
>> I mean, I think it's very weird that she sends all these
DMs to Perry >> and then there's like a spur in my chat
and seems to be repeating same arguments you're making here.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Okay. To be fair,
to be fair, to be fair, she's a spur in everyone's chat, >> No,
I know. I know. But she's a SP in my DM special. >> Yeah,
in DMs.
>> Yeah, my girlfriend's a weird freak. Yes, I'm copying
every single of her arguments. Yes, I'm ruining my relationship.
It's like flirting to me to be perfectly honest. >> It
seems very like weird like childlike. Uh I'm going to punch you
in the arm and see what you do about it. >> Uh very very
weird.
>> I know. You can unblock her and tell her that. That's
fine, too. >> Oh, I don't care. She's a freak and I don't
want to talk about her. Talk to her. Sorry. >> Stop caring
and stop. >> Um No. I think it's weird. You're here.
Do you think that the way that you talk about who maybe impacted
your relationship with
talking about her. No, I stopped talking about her this entire
time that of them being together. Okay. >> No, that's not
true. >> Yeah, it's just my absolutely not true. Huh? I
>> I mean like talking. Okay. No, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. >> Everyone's DMs. >> I'm not
thinking. I'm not thinking in
>> I think I got like 10 15
that's unnecessary trying to run.
Why is he trying to rape? Why is he trying to rape tiny tiny
tiny when you're right forgot that I did I'm sorry. I'm so sorry.
You talk about quite frequently
not going hard on her. I was leaving. >> Just say some
of the things you've been saying about
break up. Yes, I know I get
I don't care if you break up. >> I can't hear you, Aiden.
I don't care. >> You're my orbiter. >> Aiden, you
were saying >> I was going to say I think
>> you're such a brand nose. Jesus Christ.
what were you saying about Resi of his girlfriend? Go. >> I'm
trying to facilitate a conversation whereas you're just trying
to pee alone. Shut the >> AN
say something, etc.
>> Yeah, I think we need to do something about the stickers
guy to be honest. >> Can you kick parry out for call please?
No. All right. >> He's being ironic, guys, when he says
that. Totally ironic.
please go on. What have you said about >> Be honest? I
don't I mean, she's a she's a meddling freak.
>> Uh she's like she'll leave. She'll just do random. I
honestly I think she didn't uh started really not liking or had
a real problem with me. I think things took a turn when after
that talk with uh with Perry when me and Resi went on uh and
on Perry's stream uh she wanted to like be an intermediary for
us uh you know working things out working out the bridge and
stuff and when I was like I'm >> Are you going to bring
up tried to do the exact same thing? >> Whoa, don't interrupt
her. Come on, man. >> You can ask whatever [__]
you're talking about later.
>> Okay, Chase. Um
um wait what what was I just saying? >> What was this?
>> What was I in the middle saying before >> about
how Bringer was being an >> Oh yeah. Yeah. When I when
I was like I'll deal with this with Resi directly. She uh wouldn't
or no she sent me this uh DM being like I think you guys are
just talking past each other blah blah blah. I didn't respond.
24 hours later, she was in your chat, Perry. Um, going off about
how I'm I'm uh uh I forget what she was saying. She was talking
about me in your chat and that's Yeah. >> And then you
called in, etc. And then obviously she sped out, etc., etc. And
the exact details
blur. >> Yeah. There. >> Now, I will be fair. Okay.
>> There is a weight around Resir's neck. It's Resir's
friend. Okay, I will say >> got to chill. Uh why >> I
feel like I
going going crazy stall J
>> did you ever confront Resi for repeating your mistake
with Stardust or did you just like sit quietly when you had him
on stream? >> No, we talked about him in private. >> And
is Becket asleep? That's the second question I have. Becket,
are you in
>> You talked about in private so you're like a coward
loser. Okay, that's epic.
>> wait. Well, what did we talk about in
>> Sorry. What? Perry. >> Well, apparently you're
saying you talked about how you and
>> If we talked about the Stardust stuff stuff with regards
to >> and I said, "Yeah, we talked about it in private."
Yeah.
>> Um, what was the Sunday thing you were >> Uh,
did Sunday not try to get us together to fix this thing? >> I
Oh, yeah. Yeah, he did.
>> Yeah. So, there are other people as well as Doc that
didn't want us to argue, which is also why we're here, right?
>> Yeah. No, no, that's not what I'm talking about. That's
not the point. The point is that she wasn't I didn't let her
and I think she had a problem with that. Right. >> Did
end up blocking her. And >> yes, because she was I didn't
answer her for 24 hours and then she's sping in Perry's chat
after she was yelling at me for talking to Perry when he's transphobic.
Oh, I forgot. There's so many layers to this. She was like, "Why
are you going and talking to Perry? He's transphobic." So, yeah,
another layer onto the I'm I'm supporting transphobia
uh argument. So, >> Perry dating somebody? >> You
can understand why that would be particularly hurtful onto Springer
though, right? >> I don't give a about Springer. I only
treated her like a person because of Resi. That's literally it
from day one. >> Yes. So, I don't like I Yeah. So, are
we
>> I think we're all clear on all of this. >> I just
wanted you to accept uh it might be particularly painful to her
to hear you talk about that. >> You're sweeping so hard
it's unreal, >> No, he's totally beaming, guys. He's not
calling you the I swear to God. He's beaming right now. >> Resick
is everything he knows.
>> I also want to say I apologize.
>> I am sorry. I'm sorry for for saying that. I didn't
really talk about during um uh thinking that Resi and I were
friends. Um I literally she's so she's
I'm apologizing to the general public uh for saying that because
it I was I was wrong. I just don't I think so little of her that
I forgot.
>> we forgive you. >> That's Thank you.
>> But she's uh Springer is like still in the sand. Sorry.
Yeah, I know. >> Yeah, very well aware. >> I hope
you're paying for therapy >> for myself. >> Okay.
Well, I feel like we've meant reached a natural lull in the conversation,
which is awesome. Were >> you No, because there's no being
a loser. And then he's like, "Yeah, I am a loser." And there's
nowhere else to move on. I agree, Beckett. >> You good?
You done? Awesome. Right. Okay, cool. Thank you all for coming
to hang out. Um, have a good rest of your week. Uh,
I'd give you final words, but >> you're [__]
content right now. By the way, just to be clear to the death
of
>> J still J still. Don't worry about it.
>> That's true.
okay. Uh, is there anything else or >> Well, once again,
I'd like to say I've done nothing wrong and it's fine to not
like me.
>> Well, that's fine. It's fine to not be like, "Yeah,
I'm a loser and I can't defend any of my actions. Anything else,
>> All right. Well, Perry, >> burn alive. Ho,
>> stay good.
Um, take care.
>> That was pathetic. Disgusting.
>> I think you're being That's cuz
now is not here. I can say I think you're being way too hard
on Resi.
is incredibly annoying.
Incredibly annoying. Okay, I accept.
>> I think that trying to drive a wedge between them is
like is mean and stuff for my stream. My heart
>> Uh, no one's trying to drive a wedge between them.
that duck is doing? What was Aiden saying earlier about the Yoko
Ono
>> Uh, yeah, that's just observing reality. So, driving
away. >> Yeah, that literally
>> that's just saying crazy freak. You actually have to
enable this crazy freak. Doug bringing girl, you're driving a
wedge between >> You don't have to enable her, but just
don't don't point out that she's a crazy
>> She's a crazy [__]
Wait, no. Dick just said she's a crazy [__] >> Guys,
guys. Okay. So, I think I think right it would be wrong of me
to not let him know how crazy I think she is. Um because and
call her Yokoono cuz I think she's a detriment to him. Right.
I'll say it regardless. Right. I've said this to you. >> You
guys realize that like Yokoono dated one of the greatest artists
of her generation, right? You guys are dating one of the greatest
streamers
in front of his deed little grandmother. But then again, chill
out. >> Maybe John Lyn Wood. Maybe John Woods. Chill out.
Chill out, Perry. You're going too far, Perry. Only only risk
can make fun of you, Perry. You are such a brown nose creep loser
man. >> No, I think just making making fun of a risk like
grandparent who he's like is probably a little bit over the line.
I don't know. Maybe I'm a little bit on that fact, but I feel
that's a little bit of over the line. >> Such a loser.
You are such a double standards loser, man. >> Double standards.
Sorry. Whose dementia riddle grandparents do I make fun of? Huh?
What you mean double standard
double standard? Hold on. Hold on. Stop. What's the What's the
double standard? Yeah, double standard. >> Double standard
is can say whatever he wants about. But as soon as I point out
that he has the duck bringing her naked and fro grandmother,
all of a sudden that's too far.
>> Yeah, resi did call him like implying he was some kind
of creep. >> I I
mother's brain is burning. That's kind of part of the course
of Harry though, right? Okay. >> I feel like there's another
matter that needs to be resolved in this call.
>> Um,
what? What? >> I'm sorry. I I'm hold I'm I'm use I'm letting
my impulse control take over. Keep going. >> Okay. Um,
I just I just forgot. Oh, what I wanted to bring up to Resi.
Why did Why did send that shirtless picture of him to you, Perry?
>> Oh, because she said, "Thank you, Perry. Thanks to you,
me and uh my permanent slap." Like, she said, "I think I'm going
to have a long and happy relationship with Resir. Thanks so much.
Oh, look. He's so happy. Uh, look how happy I'm making him. He's
clean the pool. That's why. >> That's very strange.
>> Um, no. It's like, yeah, but um, Resi said that she
is strange and he's just going to continue engaging in the same
way. So, I guess what? You're just not supposed to talk about
it or whatever.
>> Isn't that right? >> No, you can talk about it.
That's fine. >> I think I called Yoko. No, I just think
talking about >> You said it is a little bit over the >> Oh,
you said it after. You said it after, but you also said it. >> No,
I think I think it's fine. All right. I think it's fine to talk
about Doug finger. >> Yeah, but earlier you said it wasn't.
So why' you say that?
>> Talking about the fact that his grandparent who he's
caring for is like too weak to be able to pull the trigger. I
feel like not even virtue signaling. I'll be honest. It's just
it's just kind of my opinion. >> Guys, before we move forward,
so you can see it on the point. Now we're moving on to the grandma
point. Right. >> Wait, what? >> No. No. I say it's
fine to talk about >> I talked about
argued it wasn't right.
>> No, no. I'm saying that trying to drive a wedge between
them is a little bit a little bit, you know, >> by talking
about them though. You said you're doing that by talking about
them. >> The wedge was Yeah. In the way they were >> No,
no, no, no, no. By say by
trying to say explicitly that Resir should like I don't know
break up with >> All right. This is a change in your position.
Earlier you just said just don't talk about that about just what
you said. Now you were yelling. Maybe you didn't mean what you
said. >> I misspoke. I apologize. >> Okay, there
you go. So you concede. So I won. Okay, >> now we can move
on to the grandma point.
>> wait. So you can say whatever he wants about me. I mean,
you can like rewind the stream. You can see he's being like a
gay about to me and my personal like relationships, but I can't
say >> So just because he does it to you, that means you
can do it to him. >> Yes. Yes. Yes. In this particular
case, when it comes to [__] talking, yes. >> Eye
for an eye, Harry. Eye for an eye. >> Now you're meing
out of it. So you've also conceded at this point. >> I'm
not I'm not memeing. I'm quoting
>> in the context of I think it's generally accepted. You're
allowed to like uh you're allowed to match the severity of your
opponent. >> Okay. Aiden talking about the fact that his
grandmother is too feeble to be able to pull the trigger. >> Resi's
allowed to make fun of Perry's friends, but not about Res's friends.
That's not okay. >> That's a little That's a little You
know, that's a little farther than maybe
>> Yeah, listen. He said I should be set on fire. Dementia
is often described as fire of the brain. Okay. It burns the brain
out.
>> I'm pretty sure that's strokes,
>> Oh, maybe Alzheimer's.
>> You know what? Listen. >> Well, no. Alzheimer's
leads to dementia. Alzheimer's is the disease that Yeah. >> I
thought they're comorbid. Do they lead to each other? >> No,
no, no. They're not comorbid. They are. It's like AIDS and HIV.
>> And I said it first. >> Can't you have like dementia
without Alzheimer's, though? Yes, >> you can technically,
but it's like it's like having arthritis without an immune
>> Yes, you can have dementia. Dementia describes like
the condition of the brain, but the >> thing that causes,
>> but the actual disease is Alzheimer's.
>> Yes. Or it can be
>> In some cases, non-Alzheimer's uh dementia can be reversed
in some cases. >> Wait, what? I've not heard that at all.
>> Yep. Well, there's like recent uh stuff to do with pry
and stuff, but I feel like a lot of it was like thrown out for
being based on false premises, so I'm not sure how today that
is. Listen, I would make fun of um
black buildup. >> I've heard that's still promising, but
I don't know. >> But there was like a recent
the initial research around that I thought was fraudulent.
>> Build up the amaloid plaque buildup. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That research was like faked. It was a massive scandal.
>> [__] Okay, never mind. Then I I continue
to live in fear of uh dementia.
>> All right. Well, while we're on >> start smoking,
though, >> before people start uh before people start pivoting,
um let's finish our our discussion. So, it you think that Perry
went too far with the grandmother joke. Uh but do you not think
it's like generally a generally accepted standard uh in these
like online communities that like you're allowed to enter a level
of talking that like matches the severity of your opponent? Um,
I'd probably say so, but I think if somebody's been a had to
move and put themselves in a relatively dire financial saying
I think so, but also
about the fact that >> they really have to like kind of
commit a lot to be a full-time carer for the kind of elging aging
elderly. >> Okay. But Okay. So, do you think do you So,
on the Cusari making fun of the dead dog situation, you I'm assuming
you think Cousari went too far when he made fun of the dead dog.
No, I think there's a difference between talking about somebody's
dead dog and then saying that somebody's dementia riddle grandmother
is too feeble to be able to pull the
a little bit of just a very slight difference though comparison.
Perry, shut the up. When we make comparisons, we're never comparing
two things that are exactly identical. Okay. >> Yeah, I
know, Aiden. We're not talking about two things are identical.
I'm clearly talking qualitatively. >> Comparison. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He's saying it hurt his feifies cuz he's his friend.
>> It didn't hurt my feifies. I just thought like, oh,
a little bit harsh, isn't it? >> So, you said it went.
So, you had an emotional reaction to your feelings. I was like,
oh, that's harsh. It hurt your >> I didn't hurt my feelings.
>> Oh, I just impacted. All right, that's fair enough.
>> We're talking about the relevance of qualitative. Okay.
Of course, it's going to be Fifi. >> Qualitative. Like
Reser. The qualitative difference is you like Reser, so you can
say whatever it was about me, but I can't say >> somebody
that I didn't like. I'll be honest. Even somebody that I didn't
like, I'd have the same reaction. >> Well, then you're
like a [__] coward loser. I don't know what to say.
Yeah, it's just their [__] grandmother. She's going
to be dead in [__] >> coward for saying you
talking about his dementia little grandmother being able to kill
herself >> when Resi's calling him pedophile adjacent and
stuff like he that's totally fair. >> He's insulting my
IRL friend, my IRL friend who has way more mental acuity. Kyle
has way more mental acuity than his grandmother. Okay, so that's
even worse. Okay, the impact on Kyle is way worse than his brain
dead,
you know, >> kissing old exfriend. To be fair, it is exfriend.
But hey, that's even worse. He might dox me. His eventual grandmother
can't even say his name, let alone dox him. Okay, it's up. >> Yeah.
So, I I feel like we're enforcing a standard here that like I
I feel like you're obviously probably biased cuz this cuz uh
you don't like one party and you like the other. Um >> no,
I I I 100% I'm dead set. I would probably say the same thing
if uh if I did actually like Rosie. Oh, sorry. Didn't actually
like Rosie.
>> Critical critical misspeak.
It's over.
>> Bridge burnt. You're going to get some harasser community
claims any day now. He's going to find messages of a in your
stream archives. It's over.
>> Okay. This was a fun chat, guys. I'm going to head out.
Uh, I'll ra
>> you don't have anything else going on. >> Before
you go, I just want to make sure saying it now to as many people
as possible. Uh, Starbase. >> Uh, hold on. Hold on. most
likely grooming behavior with a six >> and he's bing me
right now by the way. So he's watching he's watching. You can
say you know he's watching right now. You can say whatever you
want. >> He started botting me as well and I'm not really
sure why.
>> I I did I did to be very I have said quite nasty things
about him but still
just focus on Parry and Aiden. Okay, Star Base. Leave me alone.
>> See how it is. See it's funny because he's meing. >> [__]
over those guys. Just leave me out. >> See you guys later.
>> See you. Hi. >> Good night. >> Hey, what?
>> Good night, guys. Bye-bye.